now remind me again I I factorized up
here like so once I factorize what was
the point of doing that why do I do this
why is that useful to find the route you
had to find the roots to find the
intercepts okay so step two is to find
intercepts now don't forget there are
two clients of intercepts because there
are two axes on our cutting plate right
so there's the x axis which is the
routes that were talking about and then
there's the whitest so we're going to
wipe it up as well so off of intersex
here i'm going to say I'm looking for X
intercepts and why this episode is the
two kinds okay so how do I find the x
intercepts the x-intercepts are kind of
easy ones so I did this whole process
silica fiber what are the exit descents
won 4-2 perfect you look at the
opposites of these numbers are you sick
of me save this yet you always look at
those opposite shipping it around 14
negative 2 perfect i'm going to add on
to that it's x equals because they're
acting this s right x equals negative 1
negative 4 or two fantastic there's a
way to set it's only one of them which
is a relief because got so many other
incest okay and what's really nice is if
you remember again click back since
quadratic right I know the x-intercepts
tear I don't need to do any way to work
out the wire descent it's it's right
there that's the lightest depth here
it's just that constant flying off the
end right so the same way the whiteness
that will just be this constant hanging
on the end okay um do you remember why
it ends up being a constant why is it
just just six or just ate how's that
very good to find a way into sent you
let x equal zero right now if x is equal
to 0 this guy in this guy they just
disappeared because they're 0 which
leaves you with six here on our cubic
this guy and this guy and this guy they
all disappeared because X is zero which
just leaves you with that 8 ok so y
equals 8 is my actual wireless and
doesn't okay now we're almost there
we've got one more step before we
actually just enjoy the dots but we've
got enough information a lot to put this
onto my graph ok so draw with me a
Cartesian plane
and I've now got four points that I know
where my graph passes through right I've
got three X intercepts and I've got one
way ever set that's four dots okay four
dots i can go through so when you have a
look at this right first thing I'm just
going to put on the old x-intercepts
first so let's see here I've got one two
three four so that's negative one that's
negative four over there and then there
are all my x-intercepts there so I know
I have to pass you all these points and
my last ones the wireless net now I
could make it the same scale as on the
horizontal one I could go one two three
point c 7h but this is no reason to
really like i can just put that eight
kind of wherever I want ok so long as
what results up and down is consistent
okay so there's my y-axis there's my
x-axis I should probably stick the
origin on there as well okay now my
graph is got to pass through all of
these points hmm how's it going to do
that how is it going to how am I going
to join the dots it's my question now we
have a look at this right x is that you
do sorry I've got these backwards 14
negative 2 did you write that down long
as well I wrote it down wrong okay mine
or backwards
let's fix that
my bad there no one else picked it up
anyway that's okay fixed now I've got to
go through all of my crosses okay by the
way just as a little note i put crosses
in because I've got loads of other marks
on the graph and I want to know exactly
where I go through and I don't confuse
all these months with each other there's
one more step that will help me a lot
just for this graph and for subsequent
ones as well so many more weird were so
this is my third and almost last step oh
it's a better we were but it is I think
it's the best word we can use it it's a
very versatile word which will be useful
even when it's not a cubic that
withdrawing extremities means like
visual might be extremely simple oh
that's like I like your hands and feet
it's the far away from the center okay
so when I say extremities I mean what
happens for really really negative
values what's happening over here and
what's happening for really positive
values what's happening over there okay
all of these four points that have just
drawn they tell me what's happening in
the middle of the graph but what about
what's happening out at the edges okay
so that's another synonym for
extravagance I suppose just like I had
intercepts there's an exit wine for the
extremities there's two kinds right
there's the positive one which is over
on the right hand side and there's also
a negative one which is on the left hand
side now want to work out what's
happening on each of those so I want you
to look again at the original graph the
original graph right or the original
function rather if I put it an enormous
number for X and enormous number like a
million or a billion or a gig or
whatever whatever time you choose okay
can you see each era we talked about how
the leading tone is the most important
okay because any of these guys unlike
that'll be your safe minus six million
and this will be minus three billion
billion whatever nothing but this guy is
going to be a million million million
this term no matter what the size of the
rest of them are mr. Worf's the rest of
them does that make sense that's why I
keep on saying it's the most important
term okay so being that this guy is
going to be a huge
you got a really big positive number and
these little bits who are kind of making
not that much of a difference okay so
therefore when i put in a really really
big positive number inter miss i get
another really big positive number so
i'm coming up to here that's what
positive means okay positive this way
positive that way now think about what
happens for the other extremity if I put
a really negative number in there right
like my disability in what happens to
execute when you put in a really
negative number that's right it will
also be negative do you see why let's
actually write this out um- a billion
don't get the right number of years yep
minus million times minus a million or
going to three times x minus a million
now have a look pay close attention to
how many negatives they're up there
three two of them will kids laugh and
that just leaves me with one of them
okay so this one and this one will
cancel out leaving me with a negative at
the front and a really really enormous
number okay so therefore over here on
the left-hand side as X gets really
negative wine will also get really
negative it's going to be dropping down
okay now I'm ready to go my last step my
fourth and last step is join the dots
this is the fun part right now I know
all the places that I must go I've got
to start from this lower extremity
that's what I just established I've got
to come up to here I've got to pass up
through this intercept up here I'm
clearly going to come back down do you
see that like it's got a whip back down
to this next intercept I can go it down
through here but then I'm going to come
back up to the last intercept and then
race off to positive infinity there's
really enormous top so here's what it
looks like it's gonna pass through to me
let's try this
yeah alright something like this okay so
let's make a couple of our statements
about this okay number one is one smooth
curve one smooth curve okay if you
struggle to make one smooth kept every
night I missed the point that I was
trying to go through at the first point
that's okay it takes a lot of practice
to get this and it is actually a lot
easier on a white boy band on a piece of
paper because you got your hair like
wiggling around that kind of thing I'll
do it with your pencil and do it lightly
right the important thing that you avoid
is don't do this don't think okay I
really want to be smooth so you kind of
kind of do this yeah there we go that's
like the general shape ok no problem
with that is it is the general shape but
it's not one curve it's like 15 curves
ok so my phrase that I keep on repeating
is one smooth curve has to be smooth and
it has to be just one of them okay it
passes through one two three four
intercepts they get it down here pause
it up there and I'm finished okay